[Música]
buenas tardes
hace un tiempo empecé a involucrarme en
temas de equidad de género
en estos últimos años he visto como
género y diversidad han entrado en la
agenda empresarial del perú país en el
que resido hace más de 18 años
y producto de esto he sido testigo de
como muchos colegas en especial hombres
han pasado de ser meros espectadores
actores del cambio yo me incluyo entre
ellos
pero hasta que no me han invitado a
hablar hoy nunca me había hecho la
pregunta de qué hago yo en un tema como
este para el que no me formado y nunca
me había interesado tanto antes
tras el primer instante de pánico
masculino perfectamente disimulado
cuando aún no le invitan a un espacio en
el que nunca ha estado y tiene que
controlar las ganas de salir corriendo
acepté y me puse a buscar
qué experiencias personales y
profesionales de mi vida podía compartir
que me han llevado a ser parte de este
movimiento del cambio
si bien me dedico a temas gremiales y
empresariales ahora soy historiador de
formación
me disculpan pero me encanta leer y
discutir con amigos de procesos
históricos
en la universidad de mi facultad nos
enseñaron que en el pasado están las
claves de comprensión del mundo en el
que vivimos y cómo lo podemos
transformar como historiador o como
antiguo estudiante de historia soy
consciente de la responsabilidad que
tenemos todos nosotros de conseguir un
mundo mejor
miren en el siglo 20 hubo un
acontecimiento revolucionario para las
mujeres el descubrimiento y
comercialización de la píldora
anticonceptiva
fue gracias a la investigación y a
dinámicas de mercado que se dio a la
mujer por primera vez en la historia el
control de su cuerpo y su vida para que
decidieran con libertad
voy a intentar explicarles todo lo que
les acabo de decir tan rápidamente
después de conversar con muchas
especialistas en género y en historia la
mujer llegue a la conclusión que la
mujer siempre ha tenido determinado el
rol por los hombres en la historia
a lo largo de los años el hombre siempre
ha decidido cuál era la función y el rol
social de la mujer y este solo ha
variado cuando el hombre no le ha
importado o cuando a la mujer ha peleado
sola por ello
voy a intentar ponerles algunos ejemplos
de lo que les acabo de decir
en la prehistoria momento en el que la
humanidad estaba en la frontera con la
vida animal han pensado alguna vez cómo
era la vida de las mujeres
podemos imaginarnos a esas primeras
mujeres compañeras pares de los hombres
en las labores de caza o recolección si
no estaban en periodo reproductivo
cuando ejercían esa función que hoy
llamamos maternidad debían apartarse las
labores productivas para dedicarse
probablemente pacientemente a la crianza
quizás una mirada más cruda y objetiva
nos hagan ver otra realidad
cuando la mujer entraba en edad fértil
su función principal en el clan era
garantizar la continuidad y
supervivencia del grupo aportando la
mayor cantidad de sujetos en un ciclo
interminable de fecundación gestación
parto lactancia y crianza siendo además
el parto y la posterior recuperación los
momentos de más alto riesgo en su vida
todo eso sin contar la lucha incesante
ante el asedio de los compañeros hombres
del clan en su búsqueda de apareamiento
no hay mucha poesía en esta imagen
quizás no todas las mujeres entonces
estuvieran de acuerdo con esto algunos
pueden estar en desacuerdo con esta
afirmación pero creo que es fácilmente
comprensible que los hombres decidían
por las mujeres en ese tiempo
vamos a dar un salto ahora de unos
cuantos miles de años
para la transición del mundo medieval al
mundo moderno para encontrarnos con
nuestra segunda protagonista
hay un denominador común en todas las
culturas patriarcales euroasiáticas y
americanas y es el control por parte de
la familia del destino de su
descendencia femenina en función de sus
planes de matrimonios de conveniencia
son las familias nobles o caciques que
usan en función de su estrategia de
parentesco a sus hijas
son los padres los que empiezan a
decidir por muchos siglos el destino de
vida de sus hijas
nuevamente hombres decidiendo por
mujeres
vamos a avanzar un poquito más solo
cientos de años para encontrar a las
primeras mujeres luchadoras las primeras
mujeres que levantaron su voz
quizás un antecedente muy bonito muy
ilusionante lo tienen representado aquí
entre el 5 y 6 de octubre de 1789
marcharon las mujeres sobre versalles en
protesta por el precio del pan
les suena los inicios de la revolución
francesa el rol de la mujer fue muy
importante en aquellos días pero el gran
beneficiario al final fue el hombre el
hombre revolucionario
estas mujeres más tarde también
desfilarán pero por la guillotina pocos
años después
quizás la primera luz de esperanza para
nuestras mujeres fue el acceso a la
educación y con ellas aparecen las
primeras mujeres del movimiento
feminista mundial miren es apasionante
releer los discursos de las primeras
sufragistas de la historia
reclamaban allá por el siglo 19 el fin
de la primera democracia liberal donde
los hombres algunos pocos
además decidían por toda la sociedad
esas mujeres que habían tenido suerte de
acceder a educación algunas de ellas
empezaron a levantar la mano
esas señoras son las heroínas
precursoras de lo que hoy hablamos con
tanta naturalidad el derecho universal
al voto pero nuevamente son hombres
otorgando derechos a mujeres
tenemos que esperar al siglo 20 para
encontrar a las primeras mujeres que
pueden decidir su vida con libertad y
con mucho sufrimiento y cuando digo las
mujeres
hablo de muchas mujeres sin distinción
de clases
para acabar con estas historias quiero
contarles una última muy especial para
mí la historia de pollin polín blog hija
de judío y cristiana
se casó muy enamorada en 1966 de paul
wickens su marido un loco de los
primeros enamorados de la fotografía con
carrete digital con carrete antes de las
digitales murió una noche pocos días
antes en el frente belga antes de que su
rey firmara la rendición incondicional
ante el tercer reich
viuda embarazada a los pocos años de
casarse vivió mil dificultades para
salir adelante trabajo de recepcionista
y telefonista en un banco vivió siempre
sola salió adelante y educo a su hija
como po lin son muchas las mujeres que
en el siglo 20 tuvieron por primera vez
la oportunidad de salir adelante
piensen por un segundo en sus abuelas
recuerdan sus historias no encuentran
algún elemento parecido a la historia de
pollin
en el siglo 20 cambiaron las cosas para
la mujer
pero no cambiaron todas
esta fotografía se tomó
en el congreso en el último congreso de
lactancia materna en mexico lactancia
materna cuántas mujeres hay
este es el legado que queremos dejar del
siglo 21 a la humanidad
y si nos propusiéramos empezar a
escribir un nuevo capítulo en la
historia el capítulo en la que los
hombres dejen de decidir por ellas a
decidir con ellas
en la actualidad es mucha la presión que
hay social legal reputacional en temas
de equidad de género toda empresa
moderna socialmente responsable que
además quiere atraer al mejor talento
disponible debe demostrar que tiene un
compromiso con las mejores prácticas
laborales para todos y para todas con
equidad
qué fácil y qué bonito es esto pero cómo
se hace para cambiar el modelo en la
historia de un país en el que 1 de cada
4 gerentes y uno de cada 10 directores
son mujeres
además cuando escuchó las historias de
amigas profesionales emprendedoras altas
ejecutivas
me desconcierta escuchar ahí sus
historias de sus historias de superación
personal y crecimiento vivencias que
nunca antes había escuchado
si hicieron el ejercicio ahora de pensar
en sus entornos profesionales alguna
mujer exitosa con alto potencial seguro
que tiene un hombre encima de ella que
decide por ella
se dan cuenta el elemento fundamental de
cambio que tenemos delante de nosotros
es el hombre en la historia de las
mujeres
necesitamos hombres que aprendan a
elegir bien hombres que cambien hombres
que pasen de decidir por las mujeres a
decidir con las mujeres
hombres también que sepan callar y dar
un paso al costado en aquellos asuntos
que sólo incumben a las mujeres
no sé si
me explico pero intuyo que hay un
aprendizaje secreto en nuestra relación
con las mujeres que todavía no tenemos
claridad que no lo vemos todavía con
claridad gracias a mis estudios aprendí
a cuestionarme sistemáticamente los
acontecimientos porque no hicieron no
pasaron las cosas de determinada manera
porque no lo hicimos mejor y también qué
futuro quiero dejar a mi hijo ya mi hija
un mundo donde los hombres sigan
decidiendo por las mujeres o una
sociedad que sea gobernada por una
equidad entre hombres y mujeres
para acabar debo confesarles les
ocultado un pequeño detalle
segura and the police mamita la llamamos
en casa
sus nietos tuvimos el privilegio de
escuchar de sus labios las historias más
fascinantes que nunca encontramos en
ningún libro su historia de vida es un
ejemplo de la capacidad que tienen las
mujeres de salir adelante por sí solas
hoy a sus 107 años sigue siendo el
centro de la familia y una oportunidad
para todos para pensar el futuro que
queremos dejar a nuestros hijos ya
nuestras hijas
quizás muchas y muchos de ustedes tengan
una polis cercana que les susurra al
oído por favor estén atentos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]